[Musik]
in der letzte volk über martin bei einer
familie die plastik fastet ein großes
problem dabei sind lebensmittel im
supermarkt kommt man eigentlich sehr
schwer und plastik herum warum das so
ist und was man dagegen tun kann
bespreche ich heute mit dem vorsitzenden
der rewe group leonessa menschen in
deutschland sind verpackungs jahr
weltmeister 220 kilogramm pro jahr
verbrauchen sie welche rolle welche
macht haben da die supermärkte wir haben
sehr viele plastik in die supermärkte
das anfahren muss für viele artikel weil
plastikchips während der transport und
während die lagerung die artikel
verbessert die haltbarkeit und diese gut
für die medien in vielen fällen das hat
jetzt geht's zu gucken artikel praktiken
warum gibt es heute an der
plastikverpackung und was sind die
alternativen zum beispiel für die äpfel
aber die diese lösung mit glas papier
das sind dann klar viel besser als
plastik natürlich gesagt ist es nicht
einfach für jeden artikel warum das
jetzt für die süßkartoffel das werden
wir deutschlandweit machen weil bei dem
artikel sehr geeignet eine sehr kreative
idee sind was er überrascht dass ich das
gehört habe aber das ist wirklich
gelaufen
die mandat mit ein ein laser werden
gedroht weil ich in deutschland was auch
wichtig ist es muss bio draufsteht weil
der kunde muss sicher sein dass der bio
ware ist es heuer waren viele übernahme
noch in eine plastikfolie
das haben wir jetzt gelöst mit ein
kleiner etikett dass der bio drauf steht
und was glaube ich eine sehr gute lösung
ist die wir in über 100 märkte haben das
ist diese mehr wird frische netz der
kunde kauft das einmal und dann macht ja
die artikelreihe
[Musik]
hier ist jetzt eine art convenience tk
es gibt hier obst to go meine frage wer
jetzt ist es wirklich notwendig die
ananas zu schälen und in plastik zu
verpacken die hatte eine natur schale
ich bin der meinung dass am ende musste
der kunde entscheiden und klar bei
dieser artikel ist ja kein problem aber
bei ananas klar wer besser ohne plastik
aber es gibt vor sind viele leute wollen
das lieber schon geschnitten haben
und ich meine für mannschaften die
schwer sind wie genau ananas oder
kokosnuss oder wie granatapfel ist
wirklich der convenience aspekt so
wichtig ich muss sagen ich selber kopf
manchmal die sachen die sind aber die
granatapfel da war ich noch nie der
weltmeister ist comedy lieber so auch
wenn es muss ich zugeben nicht perfekt
was plastik vertreten
wir haben ihn ziert drei produkte die in
zukunft nicht mehr verkauft werden soll
ist das richtig also sie trinken halten
und das stimmt und musik sind davon an
die rewe verkaufe 6 millionen stück pro
jahr nur einmal benutzt und das hat
damit eine viele lösungen wie sodann
lösung gefunden diese 19 wir das nicht
mehr geben bei rede
das ist eigentlich schwierig da wir
offiziell noch nicht bekannt gegeben
aber das ist auch ein sehr wichtiges
thema sowohl die besteck also die welt
also die täler die wehren auch einmal
über nutzlose picknick und es gibt 34
ersatzbatterie an dem wir arbeiten wie
gras papier wir versuchen ende 19 2020
das auch weg von noch alle unsere läden
hat dazu habe das ist etwas wo sie
voranschreiten wobei andere unternehmen
wenn ja auch da mitmachen das ist etwas
wo sie sich auch absprechen mit den
anderen
wir haben unsere gern aber nicht so gern
dass wir uns mal sowas absprechen
man muss sagen viele reden aber wir
waren bis jetzt bei dem thema die ersten
wir waren die erste die plastiktüte
angebaut hatten mit rewe und penny dann
haben die anderen wettbewerber dass ein
jahr später kopiert aber ich freue mich
weil es ist gut für die jungen werden
schon gesprochen dass die vor allem
versuchen bei den eigenmarken zu
verbessern
plastik einzusparen weil zum beispiel
klopapier dass die verpackung ein
bisschen dünner geworden ist wo wir die
verbleibenden prosieben in zukunft
weiter wenn man die dinger machen und
weil sehr viele artikel wir die
verpackung dann gehört aber dünner
gemacht und dafür weniger material
benutzt
der rewe markt der zukunft wenn sie ihn
sich vorstellen könnten in bezug auf
plastik wie viel kann eingespart werden
da ich glaube dass spieler wie sagen wir
ihnen die kugeln zu lesen ich glaube wir
werden so viel wie möglich was machen
war ich weiß man noch nicht die frage
ist was gibt für neue alternative die
vielleicht wie heute nicht kennen sie
und die noch kommen werden darf die
geschichte mit dem laser vein 2 jahre
es gibt grass partie und wir gucken
immer nach neuen lösungen und ich glaube
wir werden jedes jahr schlauer was wir
machen können
[Musik]